regina's in las vegas hi regina how are
you
well good day dave and chris nice to
talk to you thank you for taking my call
sure what's up i'm currently under um
litigation and family court and i'm back
there again it's kind of been an ongoing
thing
my court date started in march and
because co would happen our court dates
pushed back to
november now i took out a 401k loan
and i use my emergency fund to retain
this attorney that i have
and i'm now back to baby step one so
today he asked that i take out a loan or
get a credit card to pay him
he's promised that he's going to see me
through this case but
it's a very delicate situation and i
can't do it without the attorney
what would you do if you hook up in my
shoes
uh what do you make what's your income
just about 45 take home
okay and how much have you paid the
attorney so far
i paid him a little over four thousand
dollars
okay and you're single
yes sir okay and how much money does he
want now
he he just wants me to catch up which i
owe him
right about 43 4300 now
another 4 300. yes sir
so you paid him eight you owe him eight
thousand three you will have paid him
eight thousand three hundred dollars
yes and you make 45 and we're not done
correct and when will this issue be
resolved um my prayers are
for november but i'm feeling like this
is going to be an ongoing issue and
even if we get something resolved in
november it's probably still going to be
going
well that's not gonna work i i agree
with you sir i'm just i'm
i'm stumped because i can't physically
go get alone
i'm i'm having trepidations about it
well no the problem is
you know what are you going to do this
goes on forever
are you going to go 100 000 in debt
paying this attorney no
no when does it end it has to have an
end
because you can't you can't you you
can't sustain this mathematically
i agree i think that's the opposing
council's goal
i just don't know what to do yeah
whoever's on the other side is
is also spending real money and well
they have unlimited sources they are
made off
oh yes that's why i'm i'm going through
this
again it's been almost eight years in
the making
from the madoff situation yes sir okay
um i've
i've had it's an ex-husband who
just wants to break me and wants to take
my daughter
and i am doing the best i can with what
i own and
i'm back to baby step one and in good
conscience i cannot go get a loan
but i don't know where to turn yeah
well what they have regina out there
each law firm has so many hours that
they do
pro bono which is where they give these
they donate these hours this guy doesn't
this guy isn't um and it might be a
matter of
having a real life conversation with him
to find out the time frame
his estimation of how long this is going
to take
and it might mean you're having to reach
out to find an attorney that can hear
your cause
and understand what you're trying to do
and is willing to help you a little bit
better than this
yeah i think you're going to have to
adjust your budget for uh
and get an extra job to cover this
upcoming attorney's fees
and he's gonna get them more gradually
than you just going and getting a loan
because the problem is if you go get a
loan uh and then you do it again and
then you do it again
and then you do it again this is not a
scalable answer to the problem you cash
flowing the attorney's fees
is a scalable answer to the problem um
and
so if you said all right i'm gonna i
know that i'm gonna have to fight this
ex as long as this kid is here
and uh so i know i'm gonna have twelve
thousand dollars a year in attorney's
fees
and i'm just gonna put that in my budget
like it's a bill and i'm just gonna you
know i'm always gonna have something
going on with this guy yeah and um
and so and you've got to build your
budget around that so that it
uh it's almost like a chronic illness
that you have to you have to be able to
build your
income and your outgo in such a way that
you can cover
the the drugs that are needed in this
case the attorney's fees that are needed
so
you know first thing we need to do is
get a whole get ahead of the 4300
new one and um and just tell him i just
can't go borrow money because that's not
sustainable what i can do is i can get
you paid
i'm going to take extra jobs and i'm
going to do this and that and
you know and then i'm going to start
budgeting for regular attorneys fees so
that this doesn't happen again
and um but yeah there's a
there's a lot going on in this thing
that we're not seeing 100 of it i'm sure
a lot of things going on i'm so sorry
but yeah you're going to have to set up
a situation that's sustainable borrowing
into it is not sustainable that's why
it's giving you the willies
if you just go get a loan and cover this
that'd be
you know that that would probably work
out i was going to say that'd be fine
it's not fine
but it would probably work out because
there's an end to it but you're saying
it's not an end
there's not an end no and so uh it's a
chronic
disease and so you're going to have to
build your budget in such a way that you
continually support attorneys to the
tune of ten or twelve thousand dollars a
year it sounds like
what a mess that is